as promised here he is the uh former
president of the philadelphia eagles and
chief executive officer of the cleveland
browns he is joe banner how are you joe
i'm great always great to be on with you
i appreciate you joining uh just really
keen about your insight on what what do
you think is going on right now with the
eagles
and uh carson wentz best you can suss it
out
yeah listen i mean i think it's clear
that they're uh i mean i believe they're
trying to move him
at a minimum they're certainly open to
moving him
you know if you're on a team side you
always want to look like you're open to
moving somebody as opposed to you're
trying to move somebody because it's
a better way to position the negotiation
uh and listen it looks like they went to
market and
maybe have been disappointed with the
reaction that they've gotten uh or i
think we would have seen something by
now so
not sure what that means next it's awful
hard to take a guy
who's already upset with the
organization have him be aware that at a
minimum you're open to trading him and
then bring him back i just can't picture
that's an arrow happening so i think
he's gonna end up moving i'm just not
sure when
so when you're when you're saying wence
is upset with the organization
i mean what what what is that because i
think we're
we kind of know um from afar what's
deshawn watson's issue with the texans
what what
best you can tell is wences issue with
the eagles
well i mean first of all i think that
some similarities in terms of some
breakdown and trust and just you know
personal
relationships which is never healthy but
uh you know listen if we're trying to
look it through his eyes
you know he's brought back to a team
this year that had a very old offensive
line
and their two starting wide receivers
were scheduled to be the sean watson
oxford
jeffries who were probably perhaps their
prime and have had a lot of injuries
over the last couple years
and not shockingly the offensive line
that suffered some uh
injuries and you know the way it went
down
with him being benched
i'm sure he feels like he was singled
out and
was identified as the problem as opposed
to somebody contributing to the problem
and i think if you're already working in
an environment where maybe there's a
little bit of a breakdown in the
relationships and maybe a little
almost silent finger pointing and then
you find yourself in a position where it
so publicly looks like the organization
has
singled you out as the cause of this
very disappointing season
i can't think of anybody who's uh
competitive and self-confident that
wouldn't have some reaction to that
so uh what is the you you know the the
framework for a deal like this
we saw um joe the
goff for stafford trade and the golf
contract that i'm assuming
is uh in the same area code
if not the same uh prefix as
um wentz's trade and that two ones
with goff went to detroit for matthew
stafford
and the eagles i'm assuming are not
going to be asking for somebody's
quarterback back they just want wentz
out and his contract gone with as much
coming in what what do you think the
framework of a deal
looks like for him yeah i'll answer you
with just one little asterisk i do think
if they make a trade with chicago which
will be kind of intriguing i i would be
surprised if falls
didn't come back to the eagles and be
considered part of the compensation just
because of the history there that's
okay you know trying to put two and two
together not any inside information but
it just kind of seems logical that
they'd want two quarterbacks that
could possibly start they wouldn't want
to have to use up assets and money or a
draft pick to get that so if it's the
bears he ends up going to
i'll actually be surprised if paul's
isn't uh in the deal okay
you know i think the better uh
indications to what this
could be is to look at the basketball
and baseball
where for a long time we've had trades
that were really driven by a team's
desire to get out of a financial
obligation
and it's tended to depress the quality
of compensation you get back in return
your
your main uh
acquired benefit is the relief from the
uh guarantees in this case and the
and the cap i mean the eagles would have
a huge cap charge in this year if they
were to move them here soon
uh but it would then leave them clear
after that
and right now they have 120 million over
the next four years on their cap and
i think it's about 55 over the next two
years on their caps they could eat a big
number this year and then
uh be free so i personally would think
any team uh
you know offering a lot would be making
mistake because he's clearly a risk i
mean you can't
get the play you saw last year or it's a
terrible move
so you're assuming 50 plus million
dollars of guarantees if you trade for
him
so to trade for him with the risk that
he brings assuming that kind of
financial liability and giving up
significant draft compensation
you know as we know it only takes one
team to disagree with what i'm saying
and it could look like a very stupid
comment but
if we're just looking at what the fair
market value should be i don't think
it's even close to what we saw in the
rams trade uh it's really the eagles
dumping a contract
and another team willing to take on that
contract for any number of reasons
including
that they may think he could be their
starting quarterback for a while and
before we move to uh other topics uh du
jour joe banner
uh i i i would be remiss if i did not
ask you if somebody who knows the
philadelphia market as
intimately and as you do for as long as
you were there what did you think of
nick ciriani's
inaugural press conference joe
i think we're it's good that we've seen
a lot of instances where somebody was
bad at their initial press conference
and turned out to be good because
that wasn't the winner it wasn't the
instilling of confidence you're hoping
that your players and your fans are
going to see but
i know a lot of people that know nick
and i think would be a mistake to uh
project his future based on that but it
certainly wasn't a good start
joe banner here on the rich eisen show
what is
the play of the houston texans right now
with deshaun watson
what would you what do you think they're
doing what would you counsel them to do
i'd love to pick your brain on this
subject
yeah so this is a really dangerous
position therein and
hard to know how much of itself
inflicted
you're talking about i believe probably
a top five six seven at worst
player 26 years old under contract the
next five years
at by far the most important position in
the game and right now what we have is a
lot of verbal
talk and presumably threats although we
haven't really heard it directly from
deshawn
so first thing is i'm not doing anything
with him
until i get to the point where i'm truly
convinced he's literally prepared to not
play versus play for me of course i hope
i've got a team in place
by that i mean executives and coaches
that if i can get him in the building
and get a chance to show him what our
vision is going forward that he will
actually
uh feel at least a little better about
at least giving it a chance to see if we
haven't in fact fix the problems that
he's concerned about
uh which are totally clear he's blamed
it on the owner indirectly again we're
not really hearing from him at the same
time he
we've heard reports that he's willing to
go to the jets so you know if there's
some
political race elements to that it's not
really uh like he's picking a team
that's gonna
have gone from a very conservative
mindset to one that's uh
got a liberal mindset where we're fairly
lateral move in that direction but
for me the earliest i would contemplate
trading him as the
trade deadline in the middle of the
season and i probably wouldn't trade him
unless he sat out the whole season
now i know all the negatives that that
creates with a new coach coming in and
trying to establish a new culture and
everything like that but
the opportunity to replace him it's
virtually zero
i mean you you've got to be very smart
and very lucky to get a top
five six seven quarterback who's 26
years old is right you control for five
more years
so it take a lot more than just
conversation and threats before i'm
moving a guy like that remember
once they move him it also makes every
other player on the team a free agent
contracts become meaningless because all
you got to do is
create enough of a stink and even a
great player a
crucial position can get moved so you've
officially declared all contracts null
and void it's just kind of if we're
still together this is what we'll pay
you
and i just don't know how you can build
a franchise that way i mean we've seen
what happened to jacksonville once they
started down that path now they get a
new administration
at least gives them a chance to create a
new mindset and expectation the
marketplace
but it got everybody was there fired
that they couldn't find a way to solve
the problem had to trade away players
and those weren't even quarterbacks that
make as big a difference as desean does
so
i'm i'm watching and begging him to come
in and talk to us and at least
have a face to face about where we've
been and what he's upset about what we
can do about it but i guess this is the
ultimate conundrum here uh that that
stance that you think you know or
that you would take or you'd cancel nick
casario and
and um and obviously cal mcnaren we're
assuming jack easter be to take
um that that it's such a hard
stance to to maintain
what would be however the godfather
offer that you could not refuse if
that that that that would make the
option
uh the seemingly unpalatable option of
forcing him to hold out
and then trading in mid-season if not
the after a full hold out
season what would be what would be
something you'd accept certainly knowing
you don't have a one and a two
right and you're trying to rebuild a
team with what no one no two
and a quarterback who is clearly the
apple of not only the
locker room's eye but the entire city's
eye that says i don't want to be there
and i don't believe in the new
regime i don't believe in the old regime
you don't want to build a team that way
what would be what would be the
godfather offer you'd accept to just say
okay let's move on and
do our best to try to replace desean
watson joe banner all right so i'm going
to re-qualify that i'm not doing this if
it's up to me but here's what i've said
the okay
i i've said that when they first came up
i said if the sean jackson's trade it
will be the biggest
it should be the biggest trade in the
history of the fnl so herschel what
groans that right right now is three
first three seconds a third and a sixth
and i'm telling you if i was a texans
i'm still not trading until i'm
absolutely convinced he's not coming
back
but i would need an offer bigger than
that remember
fifty percent of the first round picks
and fifty percent of the quarterbacks
even taken to the top ten
fail so how many picks do i need to use
to even
possibly replace him it's a big chunk of
what i just said
i mean i'm going to get awful like be
lucky if i have a
top 10 pick i use it on a quarterback
and it adequately replaces him that's
really unlikely so in that scenario
there he they got three ones and three
twos i'm probably using two to three of
the ones just to replace him
and i may be getting the top ten twelve
quarterback versus the top
five or six quarterback so it would take
an offer that would blow away anything
we've seen
the nfl for me to say between the
conundrum
as you accurately describe it uh and the
level of competition i'm getting this
may be the prudent thing to do
i mean could you compare this rock and
hard place
and anything you've ever personally been
through or witnessed as a colleague of
anybody else in management joe i mean is
there anything
not the topic listen i went through a
version of this with t.o
um and we stayed firm and you could
argue with hindsight whether that was
the right or wrong decision but that's
what we decided to do and i think it
protected the rest of the
roster and the team and the principles
we've built on probably did create some
short-term price
for it uh but i would understand
somebody's taking the opposite position
and thinking we made a mistake by
staying strong but
the impact of the best player in the
league doesn't come close to the impact
of
a top-tier quarterback so i can't think
of any instance
uh and i can't think of even another
sport where we've seen an instance uh
like this i mean a red sox fan would say
maybe mookie bets
but i even think that understates it
significantly yeah i guess so
where were you when tio was doing the
sit-ups on the lawn who called you to
say what was going on
joe where were you i was in my office
and someone came on and said you need to
turn on your tv
i might have been on the air joe i might
have been the one on nfl network total
access
doing the live reporting of him doing
sit-ups in his front yard
in his on his driveway joe i might have
been me
it's very possible that's very possible
but yes i was
not and somebody said you need to turn
on the tv and i kind of gave them a look
like do i really need to because i knew
it wasn't good i didn't know what it was
it wasn't good then i turned it on and i
won't really describe and detail my
reaction
last one for you joe banner before i let
you go um
how do i interpret teams according to
ian rappaport my colleague at the nfl
media group
how do i interpret his report that teams
are calling the seahawks
to kick the tires on russell wilson why
would a team
call another for their clear
franchise face why would they do that
joe
well i would call uh you know what he
got to lose and he has expressed
verbally at least a little frustration
and i'd love to know
kind of question you asked me about the
sean watson is this some i'm i'm a huge
russell wilson fan
he's looked great and i think it is in a
more complex and
more creative offense he'd look even
better so on the long shot that there's
something that answers that question
what would it actually be
that could make it worth your while
you'd consider moving him i actually
make that call
i know the odds are it's over in 60
seconds i got nowhere
they either hung up on me or dismissed
me as a fool
but i think he's such a good player and
seemingly has a
number of years left that i would
actually make that call myself and so
what do you get to lose call in my
opinion for
i think a really really tough player i
guess it's the gretzky phrase
you you miss 100 of the shots you don't
take but yeah
but but is there is there like a rumor
mill amongst management where you hear
you know the whispers that he's not
happy or or
something like that i mean what like why
you know why wouldn't i call the bucks
to see if the
you know brady's available you know what
i mean like it doesn't you know
yes this is the first part there is a
rumor mill it's often wrong so you don't
put too much weight in it but he also i
saw some comments he made in a radio
interview it seemed to be you know more
about having more input and maybe some
frustrations
the offensive line had never really been
a priority with the organization
but that's enough for me to just check
if there's more going on behind the
scenes
than you know that public comment um
and by the way if if brady would make
comments or any other of those top
quarterbacks and i didn't have a top
quarterback that made it sound like
there was a possibility
that's how the eagles acquired jason
peters he was having a
holdout in buffalo didn't seem very
tense it just seemed like kind of a
normal probably short-term
hold out we said hey what the heck let's
call them and just make sure there isn't
more under the surface
uh more upsetness was getting reported
and long behold they said what would you
give us and then we got serious and had
a back and forth and
ended up trading a late one and a four
for hall of fame left tackle so you
never know
um and when you hear there's a little
bit that this
tipping above the water you're not sure
how much is below the water it's worth
checking
so you make a phone call to green bay
the day after
aaron rodgers had his post-game comments
in losing the nfc championship game
basically yeah i may give it 48 hours
just to make sure that there's
something there but yes i do and i think
teams did
all right so all said and done if you
can crystal ball it for me and i know
that's one of my favorite coaching
cliches i don't have a crystal ball
who do you think gets moved uh out of
the quarterback carousel
when and and and all the the crazy
rumors that are flying right now
for a bunch of i think once gets moved
and i think there's a reasonable chance
that garoppolo gets moved and slightly
less but also a
reasonable chance that car gets moved
and uh i think if they weren't five
quarterbacks or at least potentially
first rounders i would say
beyond once with even more confidence
but there are a lot of teams that really
like quarterbacks in this draft and that
will suppress
the the trade market a little bit and
may keep those last couple of guys on
the teams they're on
out of all the guys you just said it
might be moved garoppolo is obviously
one that jumps out too
uh which one would you take joe out of
all of them which one would you say okay
i'll tell you
i could probably take one i mean i just
think we've seen an upside there that
exceeds the other guys
i gotta believe in my coaching staff if
i'm making a move like this i better
have a good offensive line
and i think the chance of getting him to
back to where he was is a much higher
ceiling than
i think the other two guys have i don't
need to disparage them with that it's
just a degree
uh comment on my part joe appreciate our
chats
always uh look for my texts and uh
dms and and phone calls for the next few
weeks as this stuff gets heated up with
a new league year
almost a month away appreciate it always
a pleasure thanks
i must follow on twitter at joebanner13
former nfl team executive of the eagles
and browns right here on the rich eisen
show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here